another hangout guys today i'm doing uh
an interview with fantasy copywriter
jennifer price and for those of you
loyal
believers out there uh you've seen jen
in a few of the videos but we're we're
flipping the switch today where she's
gonna be interviewing me
about how i came up with um the name
zuga for my worksheets
um i've never talked about it it's
always been this
where did you get this name and so
i love it good good good well um as you
know i'm working on a project where i'm
i'm crafting a um an old-fashioned
uh classic style uh direct response
copywriting letter um about the zuga's
and as i was crafting it i thought you
know there might be a lot of your um you
know your fans and and youtube viewers
and and you know
you know all your people basically or
might be curious where did that name
come from and i thought it might be kind
of fun to incorporate it in the letter
if it makes sense and so i wanted to ask
you about you know you know what what it
means to you i all i know is that it's
really after the chinese warrior zuga
and um i'm assuming it's related somehow
to the to the purpose behind the the
zuga themselves so i thought i'd ask you
you know you know what it means to you
and where it came from okay so the story
uh yes so
it's named after uh a chinese
strategist military strategist named uh
and
the story comes from the han dynasty
where
it's uh there were three kingdoms and
it's it's one of the i think it's the
most famous chinese book
ever written so i've got to go
to show off here
three kingdoms oh good good this is the
english version but it's it's the most
popular book in in chinese history and
it's a loose
uh
it's loosely based on history so there's
some historical value to it but there's
also some fantasy that was that was
added to it it did
i love it and the story is about
this uh
evil ruler named chocho who's trying to
take over all of china and dominate and
he's very oppressive and you know treats
people really poorly
and okay the guy who's trying to oppose
him is a guy named
who has all the right morals you know is
a good person the villagers love him
he's doing everything for the right
reasons and he
allied himself with two
strong warriors
and they formed a brotherhood there's a
three of them that formed this
brotherhood together they became born
brothers
but they kept losing
and every time they went in against
chocho they lost and
you know they kept retreating and
retreating and retreating and losing
territory and people kept following
the leader laubey because they loved him
and what he stood for and they believed
in him but they kept losing every time
okay eventually somebody said you know
the reason why you're losing is you
don't have the right strategy
you have to go see this guy
named
dugan liang because he's he's top
strategist in china
you got to get him okay
and so lao bae went to go visit him
three times to try to convince him to
join and the bench on the third time he
said yes
and that's what started to turn the tide
for them
so they had the leader with all the
values and stood for the right thing and
they had the two warriors who
you know could lead the armies into the
fights but now they had the strategy
behind it as well
that that he brought
and uh okay
and that story always
resonated with me and and i've kept the
book i had this book since high school
and yeah and it's on my bookshelf and
people would walk into my office and see
this book
amongst you know i have 10 books on my
bookshelf and they're all business books
that i love and then there's this
like
chinese warrior story what what is this
random book that you have on the shelf
and when we were coming up with the name
uh for the worksheets of the guides we
thought that
worksheets and guides are there it's
boring you know it's overused it didn't
add any specialness to what we were
creating and
uh jason who you know wanted to name it
the sheets he came up with the sheets
it's something like cooler
shorter yeah um you know
easier
and then
you know i was thinking about it yeah i
like the reason i want something
different but it felt like
we could come up with something else
and then i had this crazy idea why don't
we call it
zuga
right this character in this story and
and it was
just this crazy thing that we decided to
do
and yeah obviously has deep meaning and
has never come out before until until
today
but also
i like that you know when people walk
into my office and they see this
bookshelf
and they don't know what that one random
book is like it's kind of what the heck
is that it's the same thing when you
visit my site
if you look at the footer there's all
the the names that you know is my
newsletter there's the directory of
articles there's a youtube it's like all
that standard easy to understand stuff
and then there's zuga
yeah what the heck is that
uh right so
kind of given the same yeah i mean i'm
sure you probably get people missed
same shock value to people who visit the
site as you would kind of walking into
my office and looking at my bookshelf
gotcha so you like it that there it it
piques their curiosity and they're
asking questions
yeah i like i like the curiosity you
know curiosity is part of my brand and
what i try to build um
i agree
and i like that it's a personal story
and i like that he brought the strategy
i like that the parallel i see the
entrepreneurs is
you know
ideally you're the leader you you are
low bay you're the one out there with
the values you're trying to do the right
thing you're not just trying to make
money you're standing for something
important trying to make a better change
in the world and
you know you may be the warrior yourself
too or you may have people working with
you who can help you you know go into
battle and that could be your copywriter
or it could be your marketing person or
your programmer
but you might you need the strategy you
need the guide to help you along the way
because entrepreneurs you know you don't
go to school for this there's no real
training for this you figure it out as
you go and so that was the point of
these
these zugers was for
it's it's basically having me in the
room with you for an hour to talk about
that subject
and so right the idea of giving the
entrepreneurs their own
version of zuga and they can now turn
their business around
where they have most of the right pieces
but they may feel like they're
retreating all the time and losing all
the time
and this can be
the
ingredient that you need
to help you overcome
and uh and get better
okay
i love it i love it i love that too
because i love that there's sort of a
story behind it too because i think
one of the um
things that really sets your worksheets
apart from like other worksheets that
are out there and as a part of this
project i've done a lot of research on
you know some of your competition and
what else is out there and there's
nobody else out there that has
entrepreneur stories right so this is
kind of like the story behind buff story
behind all the stories you've got sure
okay yeah it's true right
it's not
so you know even now if you go to china
his name even just the name zuga alone
has become synonymous with intelligence
and strategy
and people right you know the chinese
culture will will understand that where
you know if you're not chinese you're
like what the heck is that words it's
a huge you know right huge that's what i
thought it was when i first saw it
that huge yeah
right that's cool like that's part of it
and then once they learn it they say it
properly and they tell others
and then the question may be well like
how did i get so interested in this
ancient chinese book
yeah
you know
and the story came from high school
where i was uh
in my high school were a lot of people
from hong kong and it was around the
time when the hong kong takeover was
going to happen china was taking over
hong kong
and a lot of people left hong kong
because they were afraid they don't know
what china is going to do to hong kong
once they took it over would they keep
their independence would they you know
lose their homes they didn't know so
um a lot of people moved to canada just
as a refuge
oh i didn't know that
yeah there were a lot of uh a lot of my
classmates a lot of my friends were from
hong kong
and okay
um
when we went over to their houses
they all had this game this was this was
made into a video game oh wow a video
game three kingdoms if you go to china
this is everywhere so
the story is everywhere there's you know
there's temples to some of the
characters there's the books there's
movies there's tv shows it's it's super
well known um so they made a nintendo
video game of it and we would always
play this game afterwards and i would i
would always be
laughing i'd always be the good guys uh
all the menus were always in chinese so
they had to explain to me what each menu
item was so you could play the game and
eventually i got used to
knowing okay well the third menu and the
fourth one down that's what it does um
right and so it got to the point where
um
one of my
friends
sent me the book
and said well there's actually a story
here it's not just a video game this is
like a
enriched you know part of our culture
and and i love the book and so i read it
and i've kept it ever since and kind of
bookmarked it and made a whole bunch of
notes um it was actually a birthday
present so i look at the inscription
it's probably backwards i guess there
yeah happy birthday evan
uh may 20th
2001. so i guess this is this is newer
2001. it was one of 1980s that's when i
was 21 when i got the book
um okay
and then just devoured it and loved it
and have like pages and pages and notes
from it and uh
yeah awesome awesome so it has personal
meaning for you too i love that yeah
what i loved about the zuga like i guess
zuga himself superman himself was he
always created
uh
he turned impossible situations around
okay found a way to make things work
when
it looked like there was no hope
and that's part of what you have to do
as an entrepreneur
yeah so
there's a couple examples uh one you
know he was badly outnumbered
and he had no arrows for his archers
so he
made these boats and and filled them
with with hay
and then drove out into the fog on his
boats and started beating the drums so
it was really loud and the chocho the
enemy uh thought oh they're invading
they're invading and so they shot
tons of arrows out into the fog
and then he would get the boat and then
turn the boat around and collect all of
the enemies arrows and then he would
drive the boats back home and now he had
arrows to go use oh
wow
yes interesting
there's another one called uh the empty
fort strategy
where
uh
he was being chased they were being
attacked they had like no men they were
badly outnumbered and
and when the enemy caught up with them
they would they were going to be
destroyed totally destroyed and
what zooka decided to do was he said
okay you know what have everybody hide
open the gates
and i'll just stand there in the middle
and they saw him
like he's alone in this city
and and here's his massive army coming
towards him
and the leader
of the enemy army named sima yi who was
his arch kind of rival
saw him and stopped the army
and
and said something's wrong
and his generals are saying hey we gotta
go let's attack there's only one guy
there we can take everything over
and
he said no i know i know zuga he's he's
a smart guy this is a trap there they
have a heat army in the mountains or
something there's a trap we're going to
retreat
and so they backed off
and and so he saved
he saved that city and he saved whatever
was left of his troops and then could
retreat properly um
by basically
you know tricking them and and uh making
you're in that situation you feel like
you're totally outnumbered you're going
to lose like it's a slam dunk
right
you know zero percent chance of
surviving and somehow he finds a way to
get through and and make it
and i think as entrepreneurs that's what
a lot of times we have to do where we're
up against huge odds and you know nobody
believes in us and
it just looks like failure everywhere
and you need to find a way to
make it through
and
that's what you know i want the zugaz to
symbolize and be a part of um
even the logo if you look at our zuga
logo
uh you may not know what it is uh it's
actually a fan
so okay um the base is a little circle
there are these points that come out of
it and
zuger liang himself was known as always
having a fan that was what he always
carried with him he wasn't a fighter he
wasn't a guy going in and attacking
people he always planned how things
would work um and set things up so he
always carried a fan with him that was
his kind of symbolic
tool yeah and so he said well we gotta
make that the logo of our
that's cool i was gonna ask you about
that but that's awesome yeah so it's
actually a fan it symbolizes his fan and
if you look at if you look at mobs
and look at his fan it looks
pretty similar to what
um we designed
yeah
yeah that's
very cool
so what do you think made the biggest
difference for um for zuga obviously it
was just the strategy right that that it
was the mindset sort of the um
you know that change that changed the
course of events for for the
yeah he
he had a
he used the environment
really well to his
um benefit
okay understand the surroundings that he
was fighting in
okay
weather conditions and you know knowing
if the other army was tired or not um
and then he played
he played on knowing who his opponent
was
and
and outwitting them just being smarter
than them and and
making an educated guess over what they
would do right like that empty the
fourth you know he
he he assumed that they would see him
and be
um intimidated right and leave i think
it's a trap yeah
there's um there's a really cool video
this is so obscure it's so obscure and i
showed jason he's like what the heck is
this video right before you understand
that it was
zuger
where they show this and maybe i'll
share the link in the description i
would love that please do um that
in china they did a tv series on this
and and one of the episodes was him and
the empty the fort strategy
and they show him basically saying
everybody get out get out get out and
he's there playing
just this instrument like a little
little violin or whatever i don't know
what it's called in chinese but this
little kind of violent instrument that
he's just playing by himself while he
watches this enemy army approach
and
and he just keeps playing calmly like
everything is okay right like he's about
to get massacred and lose everything but
he's just playing
right
like everything is okay and that's what
you know kind of makes a difference and
they retreat
and then one of his um
supporters comes up to him and said how
did you do that that was crazy and he
said you know if i played one wrong note
they would have known that something was
up and they would have come in and and
killed us all but i had to have the you
know confidence to know this is going to
work and he just kept playing even
though he was super nervous
oh my gosh
yeah so and so part of that is
you know being afraid and continuing to
press on
anyway right like yeah
to have this huge army coming at you and
you have one shot which is to play this
piece of music
calmly
and uh
and he does it and he does it and he
saves the day
um
so so many throughout the block there's
so many great stories about that and how
he
um
continues to just think strategically
and really help out
uh
you know laubey win win the day and win
the you know
for some good
right
i love that
your force of good
very cool and then um the worksheets
themselves i know in one of your videos
you talked a little bit about um
possibly going towards um you know
trying to sell the whole set of zuga's
rather than individually i know your
strategy in the past has been you know
you sell them individually kind of send
email follow-up since you have new
subscribers is that right yeah
yeah so
we're moving towards the package
um
deal i think now the the 101 which is
find your passion is only available as
part of a package now instead of buying
individually okay because they all work
together
yeah closing into the next into the next
into the next and and we found that some
people would buy an individual one and
there's a discount you get for buying
all of them together um
and i want everybody to get
the full
amount it's great to solve that one
problem but you're missing so much more
and
i wanted people to be able to experience
everything and so
um
you know for 97 bucks to get
complete guidance for your business is
um
is a pretty good deal in my view yeah
it's amazing yeah absolutely and i agree
i think if if someone tried one i'm sure
it would help but it would help a lot
more if they were integrated all of them
and they work together yeah
for sure yeah yeah okay
um
and are there any things that you're
hearing as far as um
and this is more like a general question
from people who have have
had the worksheets before um or or you
know
more just more for your entrepreneurs in
general that you're hearing from are
there any hot buttons you're hearing
from people any areas that people are
struggling with lately that um that you
seem to see sort of as a trend
the biggest struggle still is
is like mental
motivation
keeping going you know it underlies
everything it underlies
all the problems that that we address in
the zookas about how to market your
business and how to raise capital and
how to
you know finance your business how to
how to get your website going how to
find out you know your your mindset how
to find the right business idea all of
those are kind of how to's which is
great you know that that's something
that may feel
uh
in the moment
but underneath all of that is still like
just the motivation to keep going
especially if you're doing it on your
own you're by yourself and you feel like
you're not making progress you're not
getting the momentum you need
that's why with each one with each zooka
it's not just the practical advice but
also the lessons from famous
entrepreneurs
and in their words how they handled it
so
if you're wondering okay how do i find
my passion then great you know it'll
walk you through how do you find your
passion get a winning business idea and
that's awesome you end up with a great
idea but then you still gotta act on it
right you gotta you gotta go and do the
work it's not
just hey here's my idea and and it's
done you gotta you know work hard at it
and so then it's also sharing the
stories of famous entrepreneurs and
their advice around passion um to help
you realize that
like you're not that different than a
bill gates or donald trump or oprah
winfrey like they all struggled and they
suffered and they went through a lot of
crap and hardship to get their
businesses going
and you're not that far away and you can
follow in their footsteps to achieve
massive success as well
right
i love that they're not that different
that's so fantastic
because i think that's what they a lot
of people feel like and they don't
realize how much that that story really
is helpful to them because they are just
like them yeah
at just a different stage in their
career
very cool
i've been toying with the idea of
putting that video up on my channel yeah
of uh
the chinese the chinese one of the zuga
and the mt4 i think i'm gonna do it i
think people will just be like what is
happening they wanna
maybe they can refer back to this video
for the for the hardcore believers yes
leave nation who's watching this video
they'll know when it comes out what it's
all about but most people will be like
what has just happened yeah what is this
but i agree i i can't imagine i mean you
must get questions all the time on what
zuga means i mean do you
uh i do
uh a lot of people will say what's a
zuga
and so it opens the conversation which
is good yeah
people ask where it came from what the
name means and and up until now i've
just said
uh
i haven't i haven't it has a deep
meaning but i haven't released it yet
right uh jason wanted to have like a
little easter egg on the on the website
like maybe a little plane logo or the
zooka fan logo or something uh that you
can click and it would tell you the
story
but
we haven't created that yet but um
anyway maybe we'll link to this now we
have a story yeah definitely i love it i
think the video i'm going to do the
video i won't explain anything i'm just
going to put it out yeah i love it see
what kind of response do you get that's
awesome
that's cool
all right cool anything else about the
zoos you want to share with me
um
no i think that that
covers it off um i mean if you're
writing the story or whatever there's
more historical
information on wikipedia and i mean i'm
happy to provide
more information as well
yeah that basically covers
covers it pretty quickly yeah well i
really um wanted to get a feeling from
you as far as like what it personally
means to you and that you definitely
convey that very well so
that's awesome
and i think it ties in well with what
the zuga purpose is right so um you know
i'm which i'm sure is why you chose the
name so that's fantastic yeah and this i
think it's another important lesson for
entrepreneurs because when we're
thinking about the name
uh it felt right you know like it felt
right that it represented who i was the
random book on the shelf and it had a
deep personal meaning to me
and
and the story ties so well to an
entrepreneur's story
but
so all these pieces like fit really well
but at the same time it's scary
to release this word that nobody knows
how to pronounce that looks crazy
and so it's it's also like the believer
in there is believing in in what you're
doing and it's important and that it
will work out even though you're going
to get maybe criticism you know people
will
they won't understand um but believing
that it will work out
and to
create something if you create things
that you are passionate about that have
deep personal meaning to you
they will be more successful than things
that
that you're doing just to make it
you know just because other people are
telling you right i could have called it
the sheets or or worksheets or something
which was more what everybody else would
say to do with it but a lot more success
creating something personal and
meaningful that may be a little bit
harder to understand but once people get
it
again and they understand the fashion
behind it yeah i totally agree i like
that because you're right it's about
sticking with your gut and what feels
good to you and um and yeah i know
that'll work out because i i did the
same thing when i picked my word of
fantasy i was like okay is this gonna
make sense to other people like it makes
sense to me but i don't know if
everyone's gonna understand it and now i
laugh at that because now i'm like i
can't imagine anything else like this is
perfect for me so yeah and there's a lot
of fear in that
in life yeah like that but it and it's
not it's not not being afraid it's being
afraid and doing it anyway
right
right because it speaks to you and you
know and it means something to you so
that's cool
awesome thank you so much evan for
giving me the story and i'm excited to
incorporate it i think it makes sense to
incorporate it into the letter so i'm
psyched about that i'm looking forward
to it thanks for the time jen thank you
talk to you soon bye everybody bye
you